[Music]
this is a very special episode and i'm
super jazzed about it
for two reasons number one i get to talk
to one of my favorite people in the
world
my practicum supervisor a guy you know
what they told you
in elementary school if you just are in
middle school and high school
you know if you just worked harder you
could be as fast as that guy
or you could lift weights like that guy
be as strong as him it's just because
you're not working hard and then
when you're about a junior senior in
high school you realize that guy just
jumps higher than me
like i could lift all day he's just
faster
i work really really hard and that guy's
just stephen curry he just makes baskets
better than me right
well i didn't realize until i was way
too far down the road that that also
works
academics for brain computational power
i just always
you know told myself the story if you
just studied more or read more
that you would be smart like these other
people and then
i worked with dr gomez
michael gomez that we're gonna talk to
you today as my he's my practicum
supervisor and i realized oh his brain
just
works 10x mine he's just smarter than me
i could study all day and read
everything
nope he's just faster and better than me
at this
so it's one of my great honors so here's
what i'm calling him today this is
exciting
so one of my meta goals for this show
right one of the the the regular goals
is to give people practical information
they can take home and use to solve some
of personal challenges that they're
experiencing one of my meta goals is
is to show people what it looks like
to live a healthier well life and so
what i want to do is pull back the
curtain whenever i can on challenging
issues
on regular issues on just normal
everyday life for things that most
people don't get to see
and so we got a uh reached uh we got a
call
for today's show from an extraordinary
woman
in texas who experienced some really
outside of the box
trauma and she also has a
child with very particular special needs
and so dr gomez is a friend of mine and
he's a mentor of mine and he also
is a expert child psychologist
in trauma and in autism
and it just so happens that this
particular call is
about how to talk to a young person with
autism
about family trauma and if you don't
have somebody a young person with autism
in your life
this this this show will still be really
important for you
but i knew hey i need to get some some
deeper insight into this
any good counselor does this any good
therapist does this any good doctor does
this any good
academic does this when they're faced
with something that they want to get
some more information and some more
depth on they don't go to the internet
and read headlines
they call an expert and they ask hard
questions they do this about plumbing
too by the way and how to raise chickens
and how to fix your tire on your car
whatever right
so i wanted to give you good folks a
ringside seat to a conversation between
two professionals
talking about the particulars here and
so we reached out to
dr gomez and i said hey man would you be
mind being on the show and talking me
through this and helping me think
through this
particular question he said absolutely
i'm in and so i'm gonna go straight
to dr michael gomez on the phone
hola muchacho how are you doing hey dr
delany can you hear me okay over there
yeah i can hear you great man
you can just call me john um i'm now i'm
back to being one of your students again
so it's good for you well you you're in
the doctor
also that was maybe the best compliment
i've ever been given at any point in
time so thank you for that you're
welcome man how are you
doing well doing well good to hear from
you good to talk to you hey so before we
go any further
you just got some big fancy new gig tell
me about this
yes um i uh with the profession you see
list is one that will be starting in
october
um i do a lot of work that you said with
trauma and autism i
uh was lucky enough to um get offered a
spot at
uh emma pendleton bradley hospital part
of the lifespan institute in providence
rhode island which is one of
brown university's teaching hospitals um
so wonderful place amazing
team um stellar um nationally and
internationally
um and just wonderful people working
there and wonderful kids
so if you're a listener this is how two
roads diverge
in a wood
yoda gets a job at a brown teaching
hospital
it's one of the most extraordinary
academic institutions on the planet
the other guy gets a youtube show
that's how we that's how our our our
paths converge doctor
are separated went to our separate ways
so way to go man all right hey i
appreciate you
being willing to talk me through this
situation all right so
here's the here's the story
a couple is married and then they get
divorced
and my understanding and i haven't
talked to this woman yet so i'm just
going through uh an email that was sent
um they get divorced the guy was not a
good husband
but a really excellent father he gets
um has a relationship with somebody else
and
um mom and her autistic son
go their separate ways dad is still
super involved in
his autistic son's life he's a great
father
um they are have become friends again
good co-parents
and then rather suddenly he
for reasons unknown to really anybody he
murders his new girlfriend their kid
and then he commits suicide it's all
over the news it's a big thing in the
city with which they live
mom has to tell autistic child
this news and grieve herself
and she has did a great job out of the
gate talking to her son
saying hey dads your dad has passed away
man what is the right next step on
talking about how he passed away it's
going to be on the news his friends are
going to ask him about it
and by the way this this child who was
murdered in this situation was close
friends with him
right so now he's got this extra thing
his dad took his own life
and dad also murdered one of his friends
and he's a highly functioning autistic
young man so
man walking me through how we would
navigate that conversation
um both as a 13 year old and then as the
kid grows up
absolutely so a couple of
recommendations um for
both providers whether it's a therapist
nurse doctor talking to the parent and
for the parent for mom in this scenario
first i always advise providers like if
you're a counselor
talking to a parent they're going to
want you to tell the kid this
and we have to very gently tell them we
will
show you how to tell the kid and we'll
walk you through that but we
we're not going to do it ourselves we'll
be in the room if you need us to we'll
be on the phone or on the zoom camera
and a lot of parents rightly so get
upset they're like well then what am i
paying you for
which is a legitimate question and so
the reason for that is not because we're
trying to avoid it as providers but
we're not going to be there when the kid
has a nightmare at 2 am but we're not
going to be there when
you're just having sunday lunch and you
ask the kid if he wants to catch up and
he says why did daddy shoot
you like that's kind of the rhythm it'll
happen and
you know we want someone that the thing
we want to emphasize to parents the
first thing is
you are the best person to talk to them
so
the meta there is the the parents got to
have this conversation gotta walk
through what happened
okay yeah and uh now they can see just
like you said earlier seek support teach
expertise
practice with a professional uh practice
with a friend a call
and we encourage them to do that um
however
we we don't want to kind of give the
like uh outsource the conversation
basically there you go
all right so what does mom has mom has
already done man she did it great she
um got beneath eye level she with her
with her with her autistic son she
communicated dad has passed away they
grieved that together it was really
remarkable
and now what's the follow-up
conversation to say hey here's actually
what all went down
yeah i want to also highlight what you
just said which is that that in and of
itself is a huge victory and strength
for mom
yeah because like you said she is in her
own grieving process and her own
confusion and
sadness and anger and fear and she's
putting that
like i'm in this pain but i have to
worry about my little boy here and
so that in itself we we want to kind of
touch base on especially as providers
saying
hey you have that conversation yep the
other ones you'll be able to have too if
you got through that one you're going to
get to the other one
okay and and repetitively kind of let
mom know that
uh that first one is usually the harder
one even if it may not be the most
difficult one
which i think applies in this case where
your daddy passed away and and that
was hard enough itself now she has to
explain some more of the details
for him but emphasizing that you you've
already done it you already
kind of ripped some of the band-aid off
your you know you can do this again
okay we're just going to give you some
extra tools excellent okay
so walk us through the hard stuff here
sure so
a couple of rules that i give caregivers
is um
first less is more okay so and i talk
about micro conversations
um so we don't like this we also do a
similar move when we talk about sex and
sexuality with kids
we don't we're not a fan of the talk
like the two-hour talk that traumatized
most of us
that's right i got to talk i still have
nightmares so
we want like when they're little like
here's the name of your private parts
right
they're growing up why does she have
different private parts well
and those are very short conversations
so a lot of parents will want to kind of
just
blast and rightly so but we want them to
give them information and then check and
so a lot of times when i'm coaching
parents to how to do this
so i want to tell you billy exactly how
your father died
okay okay i told you he passed away and
also
um advise parents to give kids as many
options as they can within these
conversations so
the next question would be do you want
to know how he died
okay and nope okay
and then she can ask later maybe like
not necessarily that day but next week
a couple months now the only time i i
kind of show you the options is kind of
this scenario where he's gonna see it
so at that with that particular question
i would say
your daddy passed away in a way that's
on the news
and you might see it or might read about
it so i really want to tell you
what happened but even then you can give
options would you like to talk now
would you like to talk on the weekend
would you like to talk tonight
and like we're going to do it it's just
how you get to decide how
and it's almost conscious discipline
like i'm going to give you a set of
options and you get to choose
and but that's letting a child in a
moment that's going to feel really
powerless it's
allowing that child to retain some shred
of autonomy right like some stress yeah
like i'm holding on this i i can control
some of this right yes
okay there um there's a uh i don't know
if you're familiar with the canadian
patent oswald
i know his wife uh wrote about the
golden state killer and she she passed
away she died pretty suddenly
and he was telling an anecdote about and
as a psychologist i thought the teacher
who gave him this advice was brilliant
because this is what we would give
advice to for a family which is she said
don't tell her in the dark give her a
choice like
and so he took her to a park they had a
wonderful morning and then
at at lunch time he basically told her
what happened
and and he told her i'm pretty and but
that was unlike this mom that was their
first conversation about that she had
passed away the day before
overnight the cro the kid was at like i
guess an in-laws or something
but giving her options about what she
wanted to hear
where she wanted to hear it how much she
wanted to hear
but in one thing i do especially with
kids who have trauma who have
any kind of uh who are not neurotypical
is i use a one to ten skill
and if they have trouble with numbers we
do like little middle big but i usually
say
we're gonna have a tough conversation
billy so i wanna
make sure that if if it's uncomfortable
that i know that but if it's painful
like you feel like something's snapping
i know that okay so
it's a one to ten skill one means you're
totally calm
fine five is a little tough but i'm okay
antennas i'm gonna break down i'm going
to start crying or yelling or
shut down and so can we agree that if
you get to seven or eight
that you let me know and that will take
a break and then we'll finish up
at a different time awesome so take your
time and i tell you you'll hear me tell
that parents when they're because we're
not working like an er or an icu
and mom has to tell them hey kid died
get the kid your brother died
i'll say take your time slow it down
you have time right even if they may not
objectively have that time
in the moment i want them to go slower
not faster gotcha
and so in the past you and i have talked
extensively
so we're leading up to the moment when
it will say
your daddy died by suicide it's as clear
as it can be
and simple and direct am i on the right
track there yes and
i always check not not just with kids
with like who have trauma but also kids
with
fas autism intellectual disability our
current name for what used to be called
mental retardation
um what do you have you heard that word
before suicide billy what does that mean
what does it mean what do you think and
you and some of the responses are
interesting so like we had a family
where
the kids like oh no it means they killed
themselves and it was like an age like
wow that's
pretty out the way you learned that and
said anything
anything else it means it's a very
important follow but it means
my dad's in hell wait a second let's
let's and which also signals to me as a
psychologist and
now i need to get the chaplain in here
gotcha this is kind of a little bit
above my pay grade no it's
um so now it's gone theological on us
okay
yeah and what about the follow-up which
would would that be a moment to put a
period at the end of that sentence
and then to circle back and say um
when somebody wait we wouldn't want
somebody to wait until somebody school
pops up and says hey your dad killed
so and so your friend um you'd want to
have that at the same time
or would you want to have some space
between those conversations um
it kind of depends on the kid in the
scenario for this scenario
it sounds like there's an imminent and
uh and so the conversation will have to
probably occur kind of with shorter gaps
okay um but a gap is good
a gap is good and the gap can be like 10
minutes to like to basically have the
kid down regulate
so you're at a nine yep let's take a
second let's go play with the play with
our dog
and you know come back in and we'll talk
a little bit more later okay
and give me the verbiage you would you
would pass along
to let somebody know that their dad took
the life of their friend
and uh for for parents i say what
what language do you think they would
understand let's workshop that okay
and i would have them generate it um
because especially with kids now
with kind of neurotypical kids who have
trauma i can usually give them language
and the language is based on development
and the very
short version of this which i know you
understand this but just for the
audience
i distinguish kind of between three
levels of the child development within
uh kids like you know young kids to 18.
first one for your kind of toddlers
maybe first grade or second graders
is egocentric which means the definition
is a
plus b equals me and
i know a lot of politicians that still
have that i'm gonna say it's
five-year-olds and year old men but
that's not the point
so the next stage up is kind of your
mid to late elementary into junior high
which is concrete a plus b
equals c and one activity one of my
mentors taught me was
right now look around your physical area
just look around really briefly
and audience do this too and if you
don't see it
it is not a causal factor
and so a good example is like a fourth
grader
two girls are laughing and the kid
thinks that oh they're laughing at me
well the kid may be living in a very
violent household with a lot of arguing
and so he's not connecting it for him a
causal thing is they're laughing at me
so it must be
they're mad at me so he's not making the
connection from home to school but he
sees the two girls laughing at the joke
they told each other
so it has to be the reason for his
distress gotcha
um and then the last one is a plus b
equals y abstract reasoning and this is
where it can actually get kind of
theological and this is where i would
tell a parent
if they do have a faith-based community
to like let's talk to that person
if they don't they can just have the
conversation however
they feel comfortable but again to
practice that and
a really good rule of thumb and uh when
i'm prepping parents i'll say
i'll do a question that's kind of mean
like let's say like you know did you
hate my dad
and they're like why would he ask that
like well what would you say
and there did they stumble which is
correct i say you can say
i want to think about how to answer that
yep
and get can you know can we talk can we
talk about it later can we can mom buy
that get some time because mom also
needs is
entitled to her time just like her son
there you go yeah i need to take some
space
mom's got baptized too right yes and so
to go back to your question so
for an egocentric like a kid and if
you're
like for kids who are not neurotypical
if you're conceived like
are they concrete or egos i'm not sure
go to the one below
right so egocentric so go to the lower
denominator and so
for an egocentric kid would say for
example
your dad shot it'd be you know as
concrete as possible
if they know or your your like your dad
took a life
may be too abstract your dad hurt them
very badly
that he killed them then he killed
himself
and it had nothing to do with you and
then you just gotta
own that space and that weight and that
silence yeah right
yep and just silence is a is probably
the hardest part of these conversations
that's what you say but what
when you when you take a break for a con
for a concrete kid
it would sound very similar but i would
say probably the last statement that
i would say it had nothing to do with
you
do you feel safe right now in this room
in our house
do you feel safe at school like
something those really super concrete
things
that kids are might be worried about
like well is he going to hurt like
someone's going to hurt us now
you're right and for abstract kids what
do you think this will have like
are you worried about kids at high
school bringing this up for your buddy
if so what kind of plan can we generate
to make sure you feel
like you're safe over there and you can
kind of go basically your uh
your zip code can enlarge uh depending
on the developmental stage
awesome but i still kind of like work
its work off of that
i love your fault um concrete
and then abstract and again you can tell
the kid
we can check in tonight or tomorrow
morning if you have questions just let
mom know
so one last thing one last question here
um we'll keep it real quick
is um one of the most common
tools i give folks in this situation is
to write a letter
to the person who died by suicide
to write a letter to the person who died
in a car wreck
um and it's okay to be angry it's okay
to be frustrated but what i want to
gently do is to steer them towards
often when we experience when we our
loved ones die
in a in a traumatic way we get frozen on
their
current pain that they're currently
still hurting and there's something
about writing a letter to them letting
our feelings be heard and
moving them past they're not
experiencing that pain anymore right
yes that lets uh us go
my question for you is does a 13 year
old with autism i i've had that backfire
on me when working with
clients with special needs does that
work with a kid with autism
so the short answer is it does it just
works kind of differently okay
um and so one of the things uh there's
some again wonderful resources out there
and i i
i think that's a great first step for a
family if they run into trouble or even
if they don't
i usually advise them like seek a
therapist
that's probably the most uh
evidence-based is trauma-focused cbt
traumatic grief they they can and it's
actually tf
trauma-focused cbt is actually has data
for kids with autism and trauma
excellent good good okay yeah and i
think it actually is available in in
both in texas and also in your area of
the us
um but um but when we're doing that
i would also ask the parent how the way
your son processes information
do you think this would work do you
think a picture would be better do you
think he has to do something physical
there you go um do like how does he not
not just with this but how does he
process stressful information like
he failed a test or um somebody like is
bullying him something that's not
obviously equivalent but something that
will trigger a stress response
how does he best process that uh so and
we're going to mirror that stress
response in this situation too and i'm
going to make it available to him
awesome
it's like well he he likes writing story
like so one kid
loves writing stories about marvel
superheroes he just write that he'd fill
up journals of them
that was how he coped with stressors and
so
when he you know when he was in foster
care we
you know that was kind of our go-to for
him when like it's something like well
the placement didn't work out or
court got extended or you got to go
testify we'd say hey let's
do you need a right buddy and then and
so he would
that would be his thing i had another
kid hated right he just
he wanted to do something more physical
more sensory and so like okay let's get
you in our motor room
you know we'll have you bounce around
there quickly there you go conversation
um i like how you call it a motor room
that's where like my wife wishes i had a
motor room awesome
they're great yeah and so mom knows her
kid and that's what you keep telling
them is
you know your kid better than anyone on
the planet and i love it and
and so how does he usually process
stressful information
awesome um well hey dude i gotta run you
are an absolute saint and so i'm
grateful
for you for giving up your time and at
your hourly rate that was probably about
eleven thousand dollars
just just awesome grateful for you i
wish
uh you'll come see me in nashville here
soon and i look forward to hanging out
but dude i'm grateful for you dr gomez
thank you so much man